Philip Taubman what is your book secret
Empire about it's about the creation of
spy satellites in the 1950s in the
Eisenhower administration and the whole
vaulting of American spine from the
conventional airplanes up into the
stratosphere with the u2 and then on out
into space all this happened in a
compressed period of about six years
during the Eisenhower administration and
it essentially revolutionized the
intelligence business and I think played
a major role in stabilizing the Cold War
and keeping it from turning hot what got
you interested in covering intelligence
issues for the new york times started
out about 20 years ago now one day I
walked into the office and my boss said
we want you to start covering in
intelligence and it's when the journey
that led to this book began did that in
the Washington bureau of The Times for
four or five years and went overseas
worked in Moscow but never really lost
interest kept writing about and talking
to people in this field and and then the
the book was really born in the late 90s
when tremendous amount of classified
material at the National Reconnaissance
Office and CIA was opened up and that's
that's really when the story became
possible to tell why did Bill Clinton
approve the declassification of this
material I think he sensibly made a
decision that it was no longer sensitive
the materials
dealt with events that took place mostly
in the 1950s the satellites that were
considered so secret for so long had
passed on to subsequent generations
which by the way still remain classified
the the more recent generations dating
back to the nineteen mid-1970s those
systems many of which we still use or at
least their successor forms are still
classified but if you're in the business
of trying to open up American history
which I think both Al Gore and Bill
Clinton were interested in doing and you
had a succession of CIA directors
beginning with Bob gates who recommended
going back and opening these archives it
was the right to
in the back in your knowledge most
sections you you say that both Carnegie
Corporation right and Hoover Institution
both funded part of this what was their
interest historical I think both
institutions I think are interested in
American history and they're kind of an
unlikely pair in some ways I don't know
that they want to be characterized
politically but certainly Hoover over
the years has been associated with
Reagan administration and has a history
of being more conservative Carnegie's
kind of non ideological but I was felt
pretty good about getting support from
very different kinds of institutions
let's go to a story that everybody's
either heard of or if they haven't they
should have and that's Francis Gary
Powers right what what was that all
about what year did this happen and
explain what happened well what I
learned the basic story was May 1st 1960
the United States had flown at that
point 23 missions over the heartland of
the Soviet Union and the u2 and along
came powers flight on May Day he was
shot down over spared loss going to
created a huge international ruckus the
Eisenhower administration had feared for
some time that the plane might be
vulnerable to attack but they were put
out the the most kind of reckless lies
basically in the days immediately after
the shoot down at first they didn't know
that powers had been caught alive Chris
Jeff print sprang a surprise on them and
so it was when one looks back at it it
was it was both a kind of very volatile
moment in the Cold War and it was a
moment that I think changed the
perception of Americans about their
government this was you know before
Vietnam before Watergate but it was a
moment in which the American government
lied boldly to the American people about
something because in the immediate days
after the shoot-down
first we said there was no spy plane
going over the Soviet Union it was
simply on a weather reconnaissance
mission and then when it became clear
that it had strayed over the Soviet
Union and might even have gone in
deliberately the most amazing story was
put out by the White House which was
that the plane had gone up without the
approval of anybody in Washington which
was ludicrous of course and within a day
or two they had to retreat from that but
it was I think in going back and looking
at this history it became clear to me
that this was in a way a preview of
things to come in terms of Americans
recognizing that their government was
prepared to lie about activities in such
a kind of naked way that I think it
eroded confidence in the in the
government back in the 70s when Henry
Kissinger went to China he took a flight
I believe from Pakistan to get in there
was secret right I was interested to
find out in this case the u2 took off
from Pakistan it in fact this very
mission that powers flew started from
Pakistan we flew the plane out of
various places over the years but they
opened a secret base not far from shower
in Pakistan and the theory was that if
you came in under the sort of soft
underbelly of the Soviet Union over
Afghanistan and came in over those Asian
republics of the Soviet Union the radar
coverage would be less intense than it
was if you flew in from Western Europe
turned out that was not really the case
and in fact that the second that powers
crossed into Soviet airspace he was
being tracked what was so unusual about
the u2 and what did the you in the to it
and the to stand for utility they
couldn't figure out what to call the
plane when they created it because they
didn't want to identify it as an
intelligence-gathering aircraft or
reconnaissance aircraft and they didn't
want to identify it as a bomb or
something that it wasn't so they were
trying to disguise the purpose of the
plane and somebody found in the airforce
manuals that there were what so called
utility planes and there was already a
u1 and au 3 so they randomly basically
called this the u2 the creation of the
plane was a really amazing kind of
seat-of-the-pants operation that
unfolded in 1953-54 55 after a long
process in which the Air Force had
resisted the development of a
of a specialized reconnaissance plane
that would penetrate deep into Soviet
airspace and it was only because of
science advisors basically that
Eisenhower brought into play and he put
a lot of faith in science he had a
couple of people particularly Jim
Killian who was the president of MIT and
Edwin land I think an a named a lot of
your viewers know the man who created
instant photography and the Polaroid
corporation those two men really were
terrifically important in identifying
the Lockheed plan for this exotic
aircraft which in its day was a kind of
revolutionary airplane the notion was
that you would fly at 70,000 feet which
was way above any altitude where there'd
been sustained man flight up until that
point that you would cruise across the
Soviet Union for thousands of kilometers
taking photographs that would reveal
what kind of aircraft they had the whole
undertaking was basically improvised and
the Air Force in fact turned down the
Lockheed plan that was the creation of
this wonderful airplane designer named
Kelly Johnson
Kelly's plan was discarded by the Air
Force and it was only through the
intervention of Killian and land and
other scientists that Eisenhower reached
in and said let's build that plane and
he did something equally revolutionary
instead of giving it to the Pentagon to
build he put the whole project in the
hands of the CIA what did the YouTube
plane look like it's basically a jet
powered glider rather ungainly looking
plane where the wingspan was
exceptionally long because under the
aerodynamics and laws of physics in
order to operate a plane at that
altitude for that kind of sustained
flight you had to have tremendous lift
basically from the wings and so you had
to have these especially long wings but
it also made the plane very delicate and
under the Johnson plan which is one of
the reasons the Air Force didn't like it
it had no armaments it had no military
specifications of the kind that the Air
Force would usually insist on it was a
very radical idea
and the plane was so fragile that there
was something that the pilots referred
to as a coffin corner which was when you
got up to your cruising altitude of
about 65 70 thousand feet if you flew
that plane you had to fly basically
between I think it was you know 390
knots and 396 knots some very narrow
window if he went below that the plane
would stall and because it was so
delicately constructed it would
basically disintegrate and if you went
above the speed it would be too fast for
the plane and it would start being
buffeted and would disintegrate there's
a great moment when one of the pilots
who one of the first pilots who who used
the plane sort of took a look at it and
and he tested the wings with his hands
and they were so flimsy he said this
thing's made out of toilet paper
I mean it was just it was an amazing
aircraft it still is we're still using
it today how many do we have today I
think we have about 40 that we use and
it's it's an it's one of the few
aircraft that have survived over the
course of basically is now a half a
century and back in what you mentioned
earlier but what was the first year that
the first u2 was built the first test
flight took place in mid 1955 and it
went into service you know on July 4th I
think 1956 was the first day that it was
flown over the Soviet Union what was the
goal the goal was desperation basically
to find out what kind of weapons the
Russians had in those days it's hard now
looking back to imagine there was a time
like this although in some ways it's not
that dissimilar to what we faced with
groups like al-qaeda in the sense that
there was a new threat emerging in the
1950s it was the Soviet Union remember
they'd been our ally in world war 2 and
then quickly after the war the
relationship disintegrated and we soon
found ourself in a cold war and we
didn't know what kind of weapons the
Russians had and we were desperately
concerned that they were developing the
means to deliver nuclear weapons to the
United States in a surprise attack that
would have been devastating it would
have made Pearl Harbor look like a
pinprick
Eisenhower became consumed with this at
one point early on in his presidency he
became who was sworn in in January 1953
he said the world was racing toward
catastrophe and he was right and so he
needed to have some kind of intelligence
gathering machinery that could look over
the Iron Curtain inside the Soviet Union
and see at this point what kind of
bombers they had and then later there
was a equaled need to find out what kind
of missiles they were developing and in
1953-54 the soviet union introduced a
new bomber a new intercontinental bomber
that was roughly the equivalent of the
American b-52
and that was a whole new ballgame for us
because up until then they'd had piston
planes would have taken them you know 15
hours to get to the United States
suddenly we're looking at jet aircraft
that could you know make the trip much
more quickly and for the first time
really in American history we were
facing the prospect of a devastating
surprise attack from from overseas is
that the bison airplane bison karez
built by the Soviets it was built by the
Soviets again go back to Francis Gary
Powers may 1st 1960 how old a guy was he
at that point he must have been in his
20s or 30s I guess he was a young man
how was he trained he was trained by the
CIA like the other YouTube pilots he was
kind of plucked out of obscurity but
they did Eisenhower did not want to have
these planes man by air force pilots in
fact his original notion was to Train
foreign pilots he didn't want airforce
insignia on the planes this is one of
the reasons he turned it over to the CIA
the theory being quite correctly that
the penetration of Soviet airspace was
an act of war basically and he wanted to
reduce the potential for these planes to
set off some kind of confrontation with
the Russians
so powers like other pilots drawn out of
the air force came from elite air force
units and they went through something
that was called sheep dipping which was
a kind of sort of idiomatic way of
describing the process where you retired
them ostensibly from the air
course they became civilians and they
went to work for the CIA and they went
through a lot of training to learn how
to fly this plane they went through some
crazy medical tests that were sort of a
preview of what later happened to the
mercury astronauts the same place in
fact on and in Albuquerque at the
Lovelace clinic Tom Wolfe made that
famous in his book the right stuff and a
lot of them I'm sure powers among them
when they were plucked out of the Air
Force and recruited to do these missions
assume they were going to be flying a
unbelievably you know sort of futuristic
aircraft they thought some of them even
thought they might be being recruited to
go into space and when they got out to
the secret airfield in Nevada and they
saw this really ungainly looking
aircraft they were kind of stunned and
disappointed this area 51 yeah well that
the the it goes under a lot of names
area 51 is one of them and the reason
that area 51 became sort of famous for
UFO sightings was that this is where the
CIA and later the Air Force were testing
a lot of their most exotic airplanes and
they would go up to altitudes that were
inconceivable at the time the u2 as I
said is operating about 70,000 feet and
later you got to what was known as the
a12 or better known in airforce parlance
as the sr-71 blackbird which was flying
at 70,000 feet and so people could see
these airplanes at sunset even pilots of
commercial aircraft would come across
the country and the Sun would be setting
and yet these planes would be reflecting
the Sun because they were still they
were so high in the sky that's led led
to a lot of the so-called UFO sightings
out there
it's a base that was constructed by the
CIA on ground in Nevada it's north of
Las Vegas that's basically at the time
was under the control of the Atomic
Energy Agency it was where we tested our
nuclear weapons in May 1st 1960 how many
u2's did the United States have it at
that point we had probably no more than
a dozen how many times did we flown over
the Soviet Union by that night that was
the 24th flight they started in 1956
when we started and to 1960 there were
24 flights that's all because Eisenhower
terrified of flying in he feared exactly
what happened with powers did the
Soviets know we were flying least they
knew from day one
in fact the first flight must have given
that we know it gave Chris Jeff
tremendous heartburn because it was July
4th it was the American Independence Day
and he was invited to the residence of
the American ambassador Charles Boleyn
in Moscow Spaso house and so there he is
you know receiving the hospital the
United States one of the few times that
he was kind of making a gesture to the
Americans by going over there and that
very day where we're making our first
flight over the Soviet Union he was
burned up over it in his memoirs and his
son's memoir you can see how angry they
were and particularly humiliated because
the plane at that stage was beyond their
ability to shoot down dad a personal
note I was checking into a hotel in
Denver a couple of weeks ago and the man
in front of me it was Sergei Khrushchev
the son I met him yes yeah what is he
doing in this country he's I think he's
teaching up at Brown University he an
American citizen American citizen one of
the great ironies of of the end of the
Cold War is that the son of the man who
said we will bury you later became an
American citizen you know why he did it
I'm not really sure I think he he found
life here I would assume to be
preferable to living in the Soviet Union
how many years did you spend in the
Soviet Union I was there for three and a
half years as a correspondent for The
Times what were the years the beginning
of the Gorbachev era 1985 to 1989 just
the fascinating moment when the Soviet
Union was beginning to Brit not break up
but the glacier was beginning to to melt
a little bit and it was the years in
some ways even more interesting than the
convulsions that came a few years later
because at that time you didn't know for
sure what was happening you weren't sure
whether Gorbachev was doing these things
to impress the West whether he was a
sincere about reforming the Soviet Union
or not it was a great also unbelievably
interesting mystery for a journalist to
try to unravel in those first years of
the 24 flights how many of them took off
from Pakistan just a handful we flew
flights out of Western Europe and
they moved down to Pakistan as I said
because we were trying to come in where
there was less radar coverage at one
point you mentioned Iran yes there was a
famous flight in fact it was a flight
not long before the powers flight in
which looking for a place to land we
picked an airbase in Iran which of
course at that time was our ally the
Shah was running Iran we'd installed him
there in 1953 through a coup that was
engineered by the CIA so a few years
later the CIA said this would make a
good place to bring the plane in to land
and the pilot I spoke to the pilot of
that flight Martin Knudsen who's lives
out in the Bay Area in California and he
described this hair-raising trip where
he basically was about to run out of
fuel before he came into that airfield
and they had this kind of crazy system
to warn him if there were kind of
bandits in those days who were operating
in that part of Iran and they had smudge
pots and he was told that if he came in
and the pot that he could see smoke he
shouldn't land he should ditch the plane
I mean he basically landed on fumes he
said now how many of the YouTube pilots
were available for you to talk to in the
last couple of years there are still a
few around
I spoke to Martin and interviewed some
others on the telephone you know these
men for years were not really able to
talk about their careers even after the
pow'rs flight when the existence of the
plane became public there was still a
reticence on the part of the pilots to
talk about their their missions and you
know the truth is as I said the u2 still
in use today
so I think it was really only until
recent years that the men who flew these
original missions felt that the secrecy
had finally ended in fact it was only in
1998 not so long ago that the CIA held a
formal declassification conference on
the u2 and took a secret history that
they had written internally and made it
publicly available which was invaluable
to me and in working on my book how much
of what you have in secret Empire is new
for people a good deal of it in fact on
the YouTube we can stick with that for a
second I think
one of the one of the new things that's
in the book is that just before the
powers flight there was a lot of
intelligence that should have told the
Eisenhower administration that his plane
was likely to be shot down and what I
discovered in these declassified
materials was that as of March 1960 the
Air Force had concluded that the
Russians had developed surface-to-air
missiles that could reach the altitude
and had the accuracy to knock the plane
down and basically from the day that
that report landed they should have
ended the use of the u2 over the Soviet
Union but they proceeded anyway and it's
clear in retrospect as you look through
these documents and you talk to people
who worked with President Eisenhower he
was not adequately informed about the
rising danger of a shoot down where do
we use the u2 today we're using it
anywhere there's trouble we want to use
it in fact in Iraq one of the issues
that has come up in terms of the
inspections was could they fly the u2
over Iraq and the Iraqis finally gave
approval at one point and we started to
use the plane do I remember that Francis
Gary Powers became a traffic reporter
yeah he tragically he was he was put on
trial in Moscow he was convicted of
espionage and then he was exchanged for
a Soviet spy who was incarcerated in the
United States he came back and he became
a helicopter traffic reporter in Los
Angeles and he was killed when his
helicopter crashed go back to May 1st
1960 again how did we get the you to do
is it Peshawar the shower push our
Pakistan how did we get it - it was an
interesting system they set up because
you couldn't keep the plane anywhere for
very long other than a couple of secure
bases that we had established and if you
brought it in to some place like
Peshawar you knew it wasn't going to be
long before word got out about the plane
I mean this is not exactly your normal
looking aircraft so they set up a whole
elaborate system where they basically
would bring in all the supplies they
needed including the
fuel which was their specialized fuel
for the u2 you couldn't use regular
aviation fuel they would bring in the
fuel in barrels they would bring in all
the equipment they needed they would fly
the pilot in who was going to pilot the
plane because before they took off they
had to go through something that was
known as pre breathing of oxygen this is
like doing deep-sea diving you have to
get your body ready for the high
altitude and so they would breathe
oxygen for 90 minutes so they would
bring in the pilot and the equipment and
then they would fly the plane in they
would fuel it up and the pilot who was
prepared to make the mission would board
and take off they pack up all the stuff
and ship out as fast as they could so
what happened to Francis Gary Powers
well unbeknownst to the CIA and the
Eisenhower administration the route that
they had designed for this flight
unhappily and unluckily took him right
over a missile battery outside of spared
loss which is on the eastern flank of
the Urals in fact it's the city that's
probably better known as the place
where as our Nicholas was assassinated
by the Bolsheviks after the revolution
he and his family had been taken they
were killed there and that's where Boris
Yeltsin was born and grew up and where
he made his career in the Communist
Party before moving to Moscow it's a
gritty industrial city anyway powers
comes in and the route of flight for the
first time this you know the 23 previous
missions had all been what they call
racetrack missions where they basically
went in did a big circle route and came
back out pretty much where they started
on this mission it was the first one
they were gonna they were gonna fly
across the whole midsection of the
Soviet Union starting from the south and
ending up in Norway and on the way he
was supposed to photograph some new
missile test sites that we were
concerned about and some aircraft
factories and when he approached severe
loss because I said they'd been tracking
him from the moment he entered the
Soviet Union because just a few weeks
before we'd flown another mission where
they'd almost they've basically been
ready to shoot down the plane and
because of bad communications and and
scrambling their aircraft belatedly the
they couldn't catch up with it and
Christophe was furious and basically
said the next time they come we're going
to get him so he comes in and as he's
flying over spared loss they fire off
three surface-to-air missiles one of
them hits a Soviet MIG fighter that
scrambled up to attack the plane and the
Russian pilot is killed another one
blows those harmlessly by and the third
one blows up right behind the plane
basically knocks it out of commission I
mean this plane as I said was so
delicate you you know you could hit it
with a sledgehammer and it would have
started to come apart how long is it it
was the wings were 70 feet across and
the fuselage is about 40 feet so it's
like kind of like a gull and the
detonation of the missile behind the
plane basically knocked it out of
commission we'll never know what piece
came off but powers realized instantly
he was in big trouble and it's a miracle
that he survived because the plane
basically went into you know into a
tailspin down to the ground and he
managed to extricate himself from the
cockpit he was kind of hanging on for
dear life connected by his oxygen hose
as the plane is you know coming down and
then he finally just barely in time
managed to get the hose cut loose so
that he could fall free of the plane and
open his parachute so the guy descends
onto a collective farm outside his
faired lost where the you know the
farmers are looking up what the heck is
going on and they arrest him and and as
I said earlier the kristef did not say
immediately that they had the pilot so
they kind of set a trap for the
Eisenhower administration but you you
made this point earlier but I want to go
back to the atmosphere in the world at
that time May 1st 1960 Dwight Eisenhower
was about to leave office he's about to
leave office but even more importantly
he's about to go to Paris for what in
those days was known as a for power
summit which was the Soviet Union United
States Britain and France and this he
had hoped even though the Cold War had
kind of been a roller coaster during his
administration he was hoping that this
would be a moment when it towards the
end of his presidency he might be able
to lessen tension
but the whole thing blew up basically I
mean it's amazing and retrospective they
even bothered to go but the four leaders
assembled de Gaulle McMillan Eisenhower
and Chris Jeff in Paris and then Chris
Jeff not surprisingly threw a fit and
the summit collapsed and Eisenhower came
home with in despondent basically and
what had happened up until the 1964 u2
flights what difference did they make
back they made a huge difference
they basically stabilized the Cold War I
mean the irony of the plane is that it
it delivered such invaluable service to
the country in terms of stabilizing the
Cold War by allowing us to count the
number of bombers that the Soviet Union
had and these bison intercontinental
bombers that we feared so much and that
there were estimates that they were
developing hundreds of them turned out
they they had far fewer than we thought
so the fact that the plane was able to
penetrate Soviet airspace was a very
important factor in reducing tensions
and giving the United States a feeling
that it was not as vulnerable to
surprise attack and yet ironically the
missions ended with as I said one of the
most volatile moments of the Cold War
when the plane was shot down so it it
was frustrating I think to the builders
of the plane that the flights ended in
such a disaster that had sort of almost
erased all the accomplishments that the
plane had achieved up to that point I
personally had another big surprise in
this book a fellow who was a pioneer in
our business early supporter of this
network my name of Richard Leghorn
Wright had a organization called Cape
Cod cablevision turns out and we didn't
know this because of the secrecy of it a
big deal in this thing yeah who is dick
leg dick Leghorn is in a way the father
of modern
overhead reconnaissance he was a combat
or reconnaissance pilot in World War two
and after the war he went to the Pacific
to help out in the photographing of some
of the first American tests of atomic
weapons in in undersea because after the
attacks on Japan that ended the second
world war we knew we had this incredibly
destructive weapon but we really weren't
sure what impact it would have been
fired off in different ways so the
United States set off some bombs one of
them underwater out in the South Pacific
and a nearest set of islands and he was
there to take photographs of it and he
describes to this day a scene that and
it changed his life and in a way because
of the ripple effect of that had a huge
influence on the course of modern
American history he watched from his
plane as this bomb went off under the
surface and these huge ships that the
United States has assembled out their
destroyers and other big German and
Japanese vessels came up out of the
water like beach balls when this atomic
blast went off under the water and he
watched that and he said to himself we
can never have another war if we're
gonna have these weapons and play and
we've got to come up with a way of
understanding what kinds of weapons our
enemies have and so leghorns set out to
develop a doctrine which it became known
as a doctrine of strategic intelligence
which is interesting because up until
that time when you thought about
intelligence gathering for military
forces it was tactical reconnaissance he
wanted to know what your opponent was
doing what the what the forces look like
across the battlefield or across the
horizon you were preparing for the next
battle dick leghorns contribution was to
say we need to know in peacetime what
kind of forces our opponents have
because it's only in the confidence of
knowing what the threat is in the extent
of the threat that one we can prepare to
defend against it and
and this struck an important chord for
eisenhower later we can avoid excessive
defense expenditures Eisenhower was
terribly concerned about what he called
the creation of a garrison state in
America namely the investment of so much
money in defense because we didn't know
what the threats were and we had to plan
to counter everything that the entire
wealth of the United States would end up
being spent on defense and that it would
in effect weaken the country and do
terrible damage to our economy
so dicks contribution was one to come up
with this doctrine and then to to have
the smart idea in the late 1940s that
aviation was reaching a point where we
could develop an aircraft that could fly
at this ridiculous altitude of 70,000
feet and go into Soviet airspace for
hours and thousands of kilometers and
come out with pictures that would tell
us what their forces look like you spend
a lot of time in your book talking about
people and you've mentioned some of them
but I want to go over them and have you
just tell us a little bit about each one
sure and before I do that you say at
some point in your book that what
happened then probably couldn't happen
now with the interlocking of I mean dick
LaVon went on to create the itec
corporation got involved in actually
supplying camera camera for for the
first spy satellite right what what
happened in that era which I think would
be very hard to replicate today there
was a kind of confluence of factors you
basically had a president in Eisenhower
who was committed to innovation and
military technologies who had the
enlightened attitude as I said of
bringing top-flight scientists into a
kind of leading role in the White House
you had in the Oval Office a man who
understood both the strengths and
limitations of the Pentagon as the man
who had led the Allied forces in world
war ii in europe a man had been a
five-star general it took a lot of nerve
not sure current presidents would have
the nerve to basically say to the
airforce we're going to build an
airplane
the CIA is going to do it and the CIA is
going to operate it and then later to
say to the Pentagon we're gonna build
spice out
and the CIA is gonna do it and you know
you're not going to be the lead agency
for that so you had a president who had
this kind of openness to innovation you
had an academic community and a
scientific community which was reeling
to some extent from the McCarthy witch
hunts and particularly the banishment of
Robert Oppenheimer the head of the
Manhattan Project that created the
atomic bomb who had lost his security
clearance these were things that were
very unpopular in the academic and
scientific community but people decided
they would put their patriotism ahead of
their concerns about this and they would
devote themselves to the national
interest in a way that I think ended
with the Vietnam War and has been very
hard to rebuild since then the other
half of this story is the satellite
thing which will get to the
reconnaissance satellite we'll get to in
a second before I ask about these people
want to ask about yourself where's your
home originally grew up in New York City
live there now what was the family like
then my my father was a journalist we
are longtime New York Times family my
father signed on in 1929 at the New York
Times and went on to have a career that
spanned 45 years became the drama critic
and then the music critic and then later
the drama critic and what was his name
Howard Tubman and then I came along a
few years after he retired and I've been
there now myself 24 years where did you
go to school I went to high school in
New York and Stanford University out in
the west coast I suspected in the
dedication to this book there's also a
tip that somebody else in your family
works at the New York Times for felicity
Michael and Gregory right Felicity
behringer's my wife we met at Stanford
at the Stanford daily newspaper office
on campus and got married more than 30
years ago and she first she had a very
successful career at the Washington Post
then when we moved to Moscow she joined
The Times and she's now covering the UN
and your current job at The Times I'm
the deputy editorial page editor how
long you been doing that this particular
job for a little over a year and a half
I've been at the editorial page for more
than eight years now also in the back
you say you've got a brother that's
writing a book in the middle of all yeah
the very same time and in fact through a
fluke I mean it was certainly not
planned his book which is a biography of
Nikita Khrushchev is coming out at the
same time as my book and in a funny way
they're their bookends I mean you know
my book is about the Eisenhower
administration and his book is about
Nikita Khrushchev so there's there's
overlap I found it fascinating the other
day I sat down to look at his book and
read about the powers shoot down from
the perspective of the Kremlin did you
coordinate no we you know we've shared
information but we didn't sort of plot
any kind of coordination it was
happenstance
how many Tubman brothers and says
they're just the two of us and is he
older or young he's older and where is
he local he's a professor of political
science at Amherst College back to the
people you mentioned Jim Killian
that's right who was he Jim Killian was
president of MIT and played a pivotal
role in the Eisenhower administration
first as a outside consultant brought in
to do a number of things including a
central study called the technological
capabilities panel that was set up in
early on in the Eisenhower
administration which basically laid the
groundwork for all the innovation and
military and intelligence hardware that
came out of the Eisenhower
administration it was kind of a landmark
report and then after Sputnik was
launched by the Soviet Union in October
1957 Killian was brought in formally as
a science advisor working out of the
West Wing and the
White House it was the first person to
do that and he played an absolutely
pivotal role even though he wasn't a
scientist he wasn't trained as a
scientist
Trevor Gardner Trevor Gardner came in
from California
he helped work out on the Manhattan
Project and came into the Eisenhower
administration from industry and he was
a really abrasive kind of profane
Welshman who was very impatient with the
pace of preparations to deal with the
rising Soviet threat
and so he can Achaemenid on as a
official working as an advisor to the
defense secretary on technology and he
basically said grabbed everybody by the
lapel and said get with it the Soviet
Union is a much bigger threat and you
realize and we've got to start preparing
for it he was not the only one to do
that but he played a catalytic role that
got the ball rolling early on in the
Eisenhower administration
when did Edwin land invent the Polaroid
Land Camera
back in the late 40s he found himself
involved in national security affairs it
was kind of fluky he started out as a
Harvard student went on to develop
polarizing material which was the
breakthrough that led him to create the
Polaroid company and then he had this
kind of inspiration to create instant
photography and Polaroid which was of
course involved in making cameras got
involved in advising the government
various projects in World War two
including telescopic sights for tanks
commanders in North Africa and then
after the war he was drawn in
increasingly as an advisor and became a
kind of compatriot of Killians and was
brought in to central role by Killian
Kelly Johnson Kelly Johnson was this
marvelously ingenious aircraft designer
for Lockheed just a fascinating guy who
grew up in Michigan had a yen for flying
wanted to become an aircraft designer he
was a very kind of self-assured young
man his first encounter with Lockheed
was back in the 1930s when they were
designing the Electra which was a plane
that was kind of widely used in that era
and Lockheed sent the plane model back
to the University of Michigan wind
tunnel for testing and Kelly Johnson was
just a student and the head of the lab
ran all these Windtunnel tests and
pronounced the Electra to be air worthy
and Kelly Johnson ran his own tests and
decided it wasn't air worthy
and he rather cheekily went out to
Lockheed and said my boss my professor
back at the University of Michigan blew
it this plane is an air worthy and so
they sent him back with the model and he
figured out a new way to adjust the tail
of the plane to make it air worthy I
read I mean throughout your book Athiya
some sense that you went to some of
these places where these buildings used
to be and all that right for instance I
remember you being at Lompoc
yes we're at Vandenberg Air Force bases
and you finding lots of grass overgrown
on the on the launch site yeah all that
how many places did you go I went to as
many places as I could go and you know
the I wanted to go to area 51 which was
otherwise known as the ranch where they
did the testing of the plane I couldn't
work that out but I tried to go to as
many sites as I could a lot of this
stuff no longer exists I mean you know
this was back in the 1950s and so out at
Vandenberg Air Force Base it's kind of
like a ghost town where the first spy
satellites were launched it's just this
very kind of fog a cloaked area at the
edge of the continent it has a kind of
eerie feeling when you go out there and
you see these old concrete buildings
that are overgrown now and there there
are elves and some of them and they're
rattlesnakes down and in some of the
launch pads and but they're there
they've retained it they decided to kind
of keep it as a almost as a historical
monument Richard Bissell Richard Bissell
is one of the most interesting people I
encountered and working on this book
most people know him as the originator
and mastermind of the Bay of Pigs
invasion in 1961 which failed as you may
remember to the great embarrassment of
the Kennedy administration and Bissell
shortly thereafter left the CIA with a
cloud over his head what I discovered in
my research though he was the guy that
the agency turned these projects over
first the u2 and then the spy satellite
project and he ran them with great skill
and it was a combination of factors that
today as I said in the book you could
never get away with I mean there was
their little paper work he put
tremendous faith in the
Lockheed and the other private companies
that were doing the work he knew nothing
at the time he started these projects
about airplanes or satellites but he was
a fast learner and he understood how to
run a nimble organization and he's not
received nearly the credit he should for
being the man who brought these machines
into being now you also point out to me
I know I haven't Thomas for the book
about him Brett that there's he was
close to the Alsop brothers and yeah you
know Bissell was a creature of the
Eastern establishment he went to all the
right schools and he handled himself in
a way that was quintessentially CIA in
that period this is an era in the 50s
when they recruit recruiting mostly from
the Ivy League from Yale and Princeton
and other schools and this'll was a
creature of that world he came down to
Washington he basically was the guy who
directed all the convoys across in the
Atlantic during World War two to bring
supplies to Europe he did that before
there were computers and things he did
it all on cards and he could tell you to
within a day or two about hundreds of
ships and when they would be getting to
port and when they would be picking up
their supplies and then after the war he
was the day-to-day manager the Marshall
Plan which was this very generous
American program to give aid to Western
Europe so he comes out of that world of
the Eastern establishment and then
suddenly he finds himself at the CIA and
almost before he knew it he was running
these technological projects which as I
say he knew nothing about this quote
page 90 Eisenhower once told land
president once told Edwin land quote oh
I'm so grateful to you fellows who are
out of town
you can't think in Washington you go
away and think and then you tell me what
you've been thinking there's no way to
think if you live here that's one of my
favorite comments in the book there's
one just before it I think in which he
says something equivalent talking to you
Lynn I can read it yeah you know Jim
Eisenhower told him this bunch of
scientists is one of the few groups that
I encountered in Washington who seemed
to be there to help the country and not
help themselves
this was the in in in some ways the key
to to what happened with Eisenhower in
these
projects is that he was not a captive of
Washington he brought in all these
outside scientists to basically clear
the air and tell him what the you know
the bureaucracies are telling you this
you don't have to believe it there are
all kinds of things that we can do as a
nation in terms of technological
innovation put your faith in science
basically this was Eisenhower in my view
his greatest legacy to the nation as
president was this kind of abiding faith
in science and I think it's fair to say
that the two presidents in American
history who were most devoted to science
were Thomas Jefferson and Dwight
Eisenhower well there's so many more
people we can talk about but I need to
go for time to Corona right the other
half of your book not just Corona but
the whole satellite reconnaissance
business if you say that there were a
hundred and forty five launches of
Corona between what years in 1972
wouldn't it started in 1960 ironically
enough the first successful launch and
the beginning of the spy satellite era
came just as Francis Gary Powers was
being convicted in Moscow of of his
flight so there fortunately by a
coincidence of history there was
actually a very limited time between the
last u2 mission on May 1st 1960 and the
first corona flight successful flight
which happened in August of 1960 what
was the first year that the Soviets put
a communication satellite or a satellite
in orbit well they put Sputnik up in
October 1957 which was a huge trauma for
the United States I think we tend to
forget the impact of that because up
until that point everyone assumed the
United States was the leading scientific
power in the world and then with one
stroke the Soviet Union changed the
impression because they beat us into
space and the implications of that were
enormous and still rippled through our
national life in some ways was the 1960
launch of Corona the first-ever
satellite we launched know we tried
beginning we had started a satellite
program we knew that the Soviet Union
was interested we had set our goal to
launch an experimental scientific
satellite not a spy
satellite in 1957-58 period and we we
picked the wrong rocket system it was an
AV system it was an utter disaster and
the Air Force and the army I'm sorry
which at that time with Verner von Braun
who had been a Nazi rocket scientist who
emigrated to the United States after the
war to help us develop rocketry the army
working with von Braun was prepared and
able to put a satellite into orbit it we
could have beaten the Soviet Union into
space but because the Eisenhower
administration picked the wrong horse in
effect we lost that race and there were
these terrible scenes of you know rocket
launches where the rocket would you know
get about ten feet off the ground and
then explode and crumpled to the ground
it was just humiliating
how did Corona develop Corona developed
the story really goes back to the 1940s
at the RAND Corporation out in Santa
Monica California
what is ran stands for research and
development who started it was started
by the Air Force it started a Douglas
Aircraft Company in the LA area
Neil DC's yeah and it was funded by the
Air Force as a kind of innovative place
to do research and then as it became
more important that it basically
separated from Douglas and became an Air
Force supported operation for quite some
time and they had a bunch of visionary
guys working out there on the you know
right a few yards from the beach
basically in Santa Monica and they
dreamed up the idea of putting a
satellite in orbit that would take
pictures of things going on earth this
was 1946 that's where the story began
and it was really a story of false
starts and and lack of imagination in
Washington that it took until from 1946
until 1960 before we finally realized
this dream that you have a schematic in
the book that shows and I'm jumping
ahead here right once the satellite was
launched and they had to jettison the
photography how did they do that
is there a primitive kind of mechanical
system because for years they had
imagined themselves putting a satellite
up that would take
photographs the photographs would be
scanned and then electronically
transmitted back to earth only trouble
is this was like 20 years before we had
the technology to do that so finally
after many many kind of false starts
with this system someone came up with a
smart idea was actually at the RAND
Corporation that we're trying to be too
fancy here the way to solve this problem
is to put up a camera feed the film into
a canister and then drop the canister
down from space and have it come back to
earth the only thing that made that
difficult in this problem was solved in
1957 was the heat of reentry
you know everybody is now
heartbreakingly familiar with this from
the shuttle disaster with the Columbia
when you return any object from space
you come in through the atmosphere at
this incredible speed of 17,000 miles an
hour you hit the atmosphere and you have
this intense heat which is what
destroyed the Columbia so in 1957 we
that was the first time we solved this
problem of how to bring something back
from space without having it burn up and
once they solved that problem with the
nose cone for a missile they realized
this is the thing put the film in a
canister coat it with this material that
will survive reentry and then as it
comes down into the lower atmosphere
deploy some parachutes send some planes
out basically that operated you know
with a kind of fishing thing at the end
of it come along and snag the parachutes
as the object is descending to the
surface and you've got your film back
now a DIC Leghorn been involved in this
too dick got involved in that in
designing the camera for this system
this was long after you know he'd been
involved back in the tests of the atomic
weapons he kept coming in and out of the
government at first he was not a
champion of satellites and then later he
became an advocate of satellites and
then he became a key person in helping
to develop the technology for camera
when you think about it trying to take a
photograph of something where you can
see anything meaningful from a hundred
and 200 miles out in space is quite a
feat go back to 1960 again
the how many launches did it take of
Corona there were 13 launches that
failed and you can try that today try
any new weapon system and get through 13
launches without canceling the program
it would be a miracle today but in the
late 1950s Eisenhower was patient he
said we've got to have this system and
Bissell was patient that and the other
thing as a journalist I'm sort of almost
hesitant to say this it was secret
nobody knew about but you say that both
Hanson Baldwin and John Finnie for the
New York Times kept had they had a
nugget of but they didn't even know that
Baldwin knew about the u2 and kept it
secret but I mean in both cases John
Finnie who I later came to work for in
the Washington bureau of The Times was
covering the Pentagon in those days in
the late 50s and he's he was very close
to the secret of what of Corona because
Corona was operated under a cover story
and the cover story was that the United
States was doing biomedical experiments
in space there was nothing about spy
satellites it was a it was a deep secret
at that point well we're on it at that
point there was a story that you came up
with where Hanson Baldwin was asked by
the government and other reporters who
knew the secret stuff to withhold it and
the New York Times have held it he
withheld it then listen I was involved
in my own experiences with things like
this later when I joined the times there
are occasions when journalists learned
things especially about what's known as
sources and methods and intelligence
satellites the equipment we use the way
we gather intelligence and if you
stumble or learn about something that's
particularly sensitive the government
will sometimes come to news
organizations they've done it with us
they've done it with me they've done it
with the Washington Post and they'll say
please don't publish that and on
occasion we will agree with that to
protect the security of the country by
the way before I forget your kids how
old are they they're college age one is
following his parents at Stanford and
the other one is a freshman at Princeton
either one I'm going to be a neither one
byline Thomas oat showed zero interest
in journalism
was too much having both parents in the
prisons back to the satellite thing when
did we go from photographic
reconnaissance to live television
reconnaissance 1976 Jimmy Carter was the
first person to benefit from this the
day he was inaugurated we had in
operation for the first time what's
known as an electro-optical satellite
system which is the kind of system that
they first dreamed of at the RAND
Corporation and couldn't perfect in the
50s it was a monumental undertaking it
was every bit as ambitious as putting a
man on the moon and the day of Carter's
inaugural in 1977 satellite passed over
Washington took pictures transmitted
them electronically down and the either
that day or the next day President
Carter was presented with these
photographs of him at his inaugural well
again we always run out of time when
there's a lot of material in the book
and we've skipped a lot of stuff but
this thing called the future imagery
architecture most expensive spy project
in history four billion dollars is that
a year no that's for the whole project
but I gather it's in some difficulty
this is the system that's supposed to be
the successor to the the big satellites
that began operating in the mid 1970s
which are miraculous machines but the
h-11 yeah kh-11 crystal ken and they
came under different designations
million dollars if things are a billion
apiece and we decided in the late 90s
mid to late 90s that we needed more
flexibility we needed to have more
satellites so they had to be smaller and
less expensive and that's what future
imagery architecture is all about but I
gather that cost overruns are developing
it's coming online more slowly than
expected how many satellites do we have
up there right now these billion dollar
satellites that probably that's still a
secret but the assumption is that
they're usually 2 2 2 4 at any given
time some of them are our photographic
imagery satellites and others are what
are known as radar satellites that take
images through radar but after you take
us through all this you get back to the
final point and is that
with all this fancy technology we forgot
about the human contact and we paid a
price for it on September 11th you can
make a direct connection between the
development of these marvelous machines
and the vulnerability the United States
on September 11th 2001 and the
connection sad to say is that we spent
so much on these machines and we devoted
so much attention to them that we
neglected the development of the kinds
of case officers spies out in the world
who might have been able to alert us to
the kinds of things that were coming
satellites are good for a lot of things
but they can't tell you when they're
nineteen hijackers entering the United
States planning to hijack four planes
and attack New York at Washington what
what did what are the big lessons that
you learned in this book the biggest
lesson I think I learned which it is
applicable today is that you have to
have very special circumstances to
create these breakthroughs in technology
and we need them again today to combat
terrorism we need today to replicate
what happened in the Eisenhower
administration where we brought to bear
the best minds in the country and we
spared no resources basically and we had
the patience to fail before we could
perfect these systems and in fact not
long after 9/11 the CIA brought back to
Langley the very men who had created the
systems I write about in my book those
who were still alive and brought them
back to talk to them for two days and
ask them how can we replicate the
environment that existed in the
Eisenhower administration we must do
that I'm sorry we're out of time and
this is the cover of the book it's
called secret empire Eisenhower the CIA
and the hidden story of America's space
espionage by the deputy editorial page
editor of the New York Times Phillip
Tubman thank you very much my pleasure